Karl Marx Ali is still one of the most
imposing streets in Berlin monumental
buildings tiled facades two kilometres
of neoclassical architecture on the
Soviet model tour guide matthias how
explains the history of a Boulevard that
was once a showpiece in East Germany
right now we're standing on Germany's
first communist Street East Germany
wanted to show that workers were the
most important people under communism
only the best was good enough for them
the so-called wedding cake style workers
palaces were elaborately restored after
the Berlin Wall fell at 90 metres the
Avenue is wider than the shanty Liese in
Paris but these days with some 60,000
vehicles speeding through it it's more a
busy thoroughfare than anything else
it's not an inviting Boulevard its
monumental architecture nothing that
really invites you to stroll along it
then there's all this traffic and even
with the businesses here it still lacks
sophistication
art galleries publishing houses and
architecture firms are now moving here
taking advantage of the impressive glass
shop fronts the cavalry Vagner and
partner has moved into the premises of
inter food the former East German
airline I always found this street very
interesting an architectural monument
those slightly empty but that too has
its attractions and as a contemporary
gallery we always look for surroundings
that have something to do with our own
themes which is also exciting and maybe
a bit rough rough is for several years
more and more young people have been
moving to Carroll Marx alley which used
to be called Stalin alley the beginning
of construction was accompanied by an
unprecedented propaganda campaign
the alley is Irish that the street was
designed as part of a national
rebuilding program and here are two
propaganda posters from the time here it
says everyone helped build the German
capital anew many citizens volunteered
after they'd finished work enthusiasm
was tremendous but in 1953 the East
German regime raised what quotas across
the country without increasing pay the
construction workers on stallion alley
went on strike and many people joined
them the mass protests led to the
popular uprising of June the 17th which
was ultimately quashed with the aid of
the Soviet Army masses for me for me
this is one of the biggest symbols here
although it's unintentional the fact
that the uprising began here of all
places
the discrepancy between ideology and
reality was enormous
but Karl Marx Ally doesn't have just one
face it's somehow a majestic viel this
street which now belongs to a bygone
system I have to say I think this
streets quite hideous but it has to stay
it's valuable as a symbol of an
historical time that must not be
forgotten the moneys for this and that
it's evening on Karl Marx alley in
communist days this used to be a beauty
parlor now it houses Bob Abbott a pub
and art space
gallery owner Kai vogner wishes there
were more such places on Karl Marx alley
if there were plenty of interesting
shops to increase the time people spent
here calm axelay would certainly become
a new place to stroll at the present
it's more a place where people go with a
specific aim if they're interested in
art culture design or architecture
twenty-five years after the fall of the
Berlin Wall the city's largest
architectural Monument Karl Marx alley
is still changing